I don't know I lose count these days as
you get older your sense of light repeat
goes off right Entertainment Tonight
Canada so I mean do you always get the
girl is this something that you that's
been happening since since your early
days the movies are supposed I know but
I feel like sometimes art imitates real
life you know my real life was not like
what I'm doing there believe me
you know for the movies that we do the
hero has to win you know if there's a
girl if there's a if there's a great of
a protagonist in there and she's a
female you got you gotta connect but to
write comes with the territory
right you got it so how amazing you know
Jessica's been saying how amazing how
amazing you were how amazing was she
unsaid she's fantastic
you know she come she comes in with a
with an attitude to do something so you
know that she really cares about what
she does and I think that's the
testament to doing good work is then and
you know shocked and surprised at how
tough she really is she she was kicking
people in the in the nads as she was
giving him a good elbow and you know she
looks so good doing it's very difficult
to do that because you need you know you
need some kind of explosive power and if
you if you sloppy and slow you know it's
not that easy so she made it look really
good and she's just she's like a natural
at it so yeah she's got all the UH she's
got all the the strings on the guitar
you know that's great how different is
this a small scale action movie in
comparison to like a large scar acting
movie with it with a lot more of cast
such as what you mean like a big budget
actually budget action film was a
thousand moving parts like say fast and
furious or the Expendables or something
else you've done in comparison to this
well I mean this is a much more
contained sort of an action film we
don't have the the resources in terms of
the money to do anything close to what
you know those movies can do because you
know it's it's like it's like you know
getting in a car race you you know the
four
he's quite expensive because we're not
in the Ferrari but we're still in the
race you know I mean we're we're still
trying to make the best of something we
can do but so what it does it it
condenses us to try to do action more
sort of in camera we don't have those
bigger sort of set pieces and the luxury
that some of those have you know it's
sometimes it's a good thing but it's in
a way it's more difficult and we don't
have you know we don't have the
resources basically how amazing as fast
and furious gonna be a lot of people
looking forward to that from yeah it's
great you know I don't know how they do
each time they kind of make it better
there's always a with they've got a
desire to one-up each time they do it
and they said this is gonna be the best
one ever the last one now this one's
gonna be the best one ever so you know
they really believe that and everyone
puts in the kind of effort to make it
that way
you know Dwayne comes everybody's coming
in doing their bit I was gonna say how
is he getting back together with the
cast yeah it's great there's a good
bunch you know they're a funny Bunch and
you know I
tory's have you in hysterics all day and
you know then they're so different in
their own way and it's great to go to
work with them all cool thanks for him
here yeah